it's time we set the record straight on
the perfect macro split to meet your
Wellness
[Music]
goal hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
to aby's Kitchen in today's video we're
going to be looking at what the science
says about the best proportions of
protein fat and carbs that we should be
aiming for in our diet a huge thank you
to my friends that unlocked Fitness and
Nutrition who helped with the research
on this Eric Williamson is an RD and PhD
and this is his unique specialty so if
you're looking for any kind of
one-on-one support for evidence-based
diet Consulting for Fitness or weight
loss they are your people so I'm going
to be leaving a link them below also
keep in mind that I am not suggesting
anybody meticulously count out calories
or macros in this case this is simply to
help answer questions that I get all the
time about General balanced dietary
patterns let me pop in here super quick
folks cuz I'm so excited to be working
with element this is a product that I
was using years ago when I was on my
breastfeeding sagga and it really helped
me recover and I also use it a lot in
the summer when I'm playing tennis in
the Heat and it's always in my bag when
I travel not to mention a lot of my
colleagues who work in Sports Nutrition
swear by element specifically because
it's got a science backed electrolyte
ratio of a, mg sodium 200 Mig potassium
and 60 Mig magnesium and it's got no
colors sugars or fillers I've also found
that having my electrolytes in the
morning has had a really big positive
impact on my sleep so even on days when
I'm not sweating a lot I will usually
still have half a packet I love all
things spicy so the mango chili is
always my fave but they've got nine
different flavors including their new
chocolate caramel which is so strangely
addictive right now element is offering
my viewers a free sample pack with any
order so that's eight single serving
packets free with any element order this
is a great way to try eight other
flavors or share element with a salty
friend so get yours at drink element.com
slabby sharp and this deal is only
available through my link so you have to
go to d r i n k l m nt.com
slabby sharp and thank you guys again to
element for sponsoring don't forget to
go to my description and hit up the link
drink element.com
slabby to get yours today okay so
remember when the it diet was If It Fits
your Macros and Bros online were trying
to convince one another that eating five
Pop-Tarts for breakfast when trying to
lose weight was like a solid plan well
that was based on this assumption that
body comp comes down to a specific split
of carbs protein and fats aka the three
macronutrients our bodies depend on to
thrive so I talked about why 100
calories of Pop-Tarts might not be the
same as like 100 calories of rice in my
video right here but assuming we're
choosing whole food sources is there a
perfect Universal macro split that we
should all be adhering to well let's
break it down by primary goals first up
let's talk General health goals and I'm
going to try to build a little Bento Box
situation here based on these General
recommendations keeping in mind that
this should not be copied or followed
this is not precise this is not an exact
science because Foods don't just contain
one macro so just let to keep in mind
I'm showcasing this top level here for
for comparison sake so major health
authorities have crafted a recommended
macro split for the general population
called the amdrs so this split has some
flexibility because these things don't
need to be exact but it's Loosely 45 to
65% of calories from carbohydrates 10 to
35% of calories from protein and 20 to
30% of your calories from fat so these
ranges are based on what is associated
with reduced risk of chronic disease
however when you dive in our absolute
minimum needs are actually pretty low
for carbohydrates and fat and one could
argue that we don't actually have
minimal needs for carbohydrates
considering that our bodies can enter a
state of ketosis to help Keep Us Alive
in the absence of carbs now fat needs
are actually quite low as well excluding
the minimal needs for essential fatty
acids like Omega 6s and Omega-3s that
said going below the amdrs can increase
the risk of hormonal dysfunction so
consuming below 20% of energy from from
fat can increase the risk of reduced
testosterone in men and reduced estrogen
in women and going below 35% of energy
needs from carbs has also been shown to
increase the risk of low testosterone in
men and am Menara in active women
particularly when accompanied by a low
calorie diet now a large reason for this
macro spit recommendation is not just
about the fat protein and carbs
themselves but about the micronutrients
that this dietary pattern tends to
encourage so for example although
vitamin and mineral defic deficiencies
leading to disease are rare carbohydrate
restricted diets can result in
suboptimal levels of thamin fully
vitamin C magnesium and fiber and on the
other hand a fat restricted diet can
result in suboptimal intakes of vitamin
E and Omega-3s so this is generally why
we recommend balance over restriction
but that leaves us with protein so aside
from water we have a greater need for
protein than any other macronutrient
because a large proportion of our body
is made up of protein so the recommended
protein intake for government guidelines
is8 G per kilogram as the minimum to
prevent disease but we don't just want
to survive we want to thrive so the
optimal intake for protein for General
Health is at least 1.2 gam per kilogram
per day or around 15% of your calories
this is particularly important for
preventing muscle loss as we age and
it's basically what most people on
non-restrictive diets are kind of
getting anyway so to quickly complet
recap this section if the goal is to
maintain good health a very diet
consisting mostly of Whole Foods 45 to
65% from carbohydrate 20 to 35% from fat
and a protein intake of at least 1.2 G
per kilogram or around 15 to 35% will be
ideal for most adults next let's talk
about the ideal macro ranges for weight
loss so although the keto and frugivores
could argue all day about whether we
should be limiting carbs or fat
respectively the reality is it actually
doesn't matter that much when it comes
to fat loss rate in fact the differences
have been described as physiologically
meaningless not just that but according
to the diet fits research study there
was no difference in Fat Loss rates
regardless of whether someone had the
genetics to supposedly present as more
fat responsive or more carb responsive
or how insulin sensitive somebody
actually was some people will just find
lowfat easier and some people will find
low carb easier long-term tolerance and
adherence is really what matters most
when it comes to weight loss success so
we now know that specific amounts of
carbs and fat are less important when it
comes to weight loss let's talk about
what is important as a macro protein
protein is the one macronutrient that
can make a difference in Fat Loss rates
so higher protein intakes have been
shown to result in more weight loss and
less lean mass loss resulting in as much
as a three time greater effect on fat
loss when going from a diet that is
about 10 to 15% protein to one that is
20 to 30% protein and there's a few main
reasons why this is number one protein
is King in the satiety hierarchy in my
Hunger crushing combo so it helps with
appetite control and diet adherence
better than any other food component so
for example one study found that people
spontaneously ate over 400 calories less
when they increase calories from protein
from 15 to 30% number two protein uses
more energy for processes such as
protein synthesis which burns calories
and can therefore contribute to the
calorie deficit and number three you
need more protein to stimulate protein
synthesis when you're in a calorie
deficit on a diet so a higher protein
intake helps to spare muscle mass from
being broken down as fuel so yeah
protein is King for weight loss but how
much is enough hey I got you guys
protein shakes awesome I love protein
protein protein protein protein well
ultimately this is really going to
depend on the size of the calorie
deficit a greater percentage of energy
deficiency for weight loss the more
protein is recommended if we consider
that most people should be aiming for5
to 1% weight loss per week which is a
rate that also allows for optimal
retention of muscle mass that would
coincide with about a 20% deficit and at
least 1.8 G per kilogram of protein okay
so in summary the percentage from carbs
and fat matter a lot less than protein
when it comes to weight loss but while
we are in a calorie deficit we want to
push our protein intake towards around
the 30% range and at least 1.8 Gams per
kilogram while maintaining the general
amdrs for carbs and fat also please
remember that weight loss is both
difficult and can pose a risk for your
relationship with food so always work
with a dietitian like one from unlocked
if this is your goal to help both reduce
this risk and increase your chances of
keeping it off so as we've now seen
there's a baseline for protein that
unless you're on an extreme friger diet
or just not eating enough calories
period you are almost surely meeting
needs will increase when in a calorie
deficit and they can potentially
increase on a per kilogram a body weight
basis even further when the goal is
muscle gain as this systematic review
found optimal muscle mass gains come at
1.6 to 2.2 G per kilogram per day of
protein intake so that is around 75 to 1
gam per pound of body weight but because
only so much protein can be used for
muscle protein synthesis in one sitting
research like this review paper from our
friend Eric at unlock nutrition shows
that it's important to spread your
intake out with at least. 3 G per
kilogram per meal in four to five meals
or snacks per day so usually this is
around the 20 to 35 G per meal Mark
again the other macronutrients are
arguably less important for muscle gain
but there is evidence that sticking to a
very low carb diet can potentially
result in lower performance of strength
training workouts which would impact
your rate of muscle and strength gain
over time giving a slight Edge over fat
when it comes to importance to summarize
if muscle gain is the goal you're not
going to be in that same calorie deficit
that you might be for weight loss you
might even be in a caloric Surplus so
even though the total grams per kilogram
of protein could potentially be around
the same or even higher around 1.6 to
2.2 G per kilogram the percentage of
calories from protein is lower than that
is seen with weight loss when we have to
be more mindful of muscle sparing so
generally this looks like about 20% of
calories from protein per day spread out
between several meals and again staying
within the amdr ranges for carbs and fat
and finally let's talk about endurance
exercise goals so things like moderate
to vigorous longer sessions of things
like running biking swimming Etc here
the tables turn and carbohydrates start
to really really matter as you can see
in this chart right here the higher the
intensity and longer the workout the
more carbohydrate is needed to help fuel
the activity and refill those glycogen
stores we also need to consider protein
this one actually might surprise you but
folks who are endurance training for at
least 1 to 2 hours of at least moderate
intensity training actually need about
1.8 g of protein per kilogram which is
on par with the recommendations for
weight loss and muscle gain and this is
because protein is used as a fuel source
during endurance training and what you
burn off needs to be replaced afterwards
also don't forget that protein is
important for a lot more than just
muscle size there are so many different
adaptations to endurance exercise that
involves our proteins in our body so
things like the mitochondria blood
vessels the heart Etc this was actually
part of Eric from unlocks PhD thesis who
suggested that if you're exercising for
over an hour of at least moderate
intensity you should be aiming for about
1.8 g of protein per kilogram or 15% of
energy needs from protein whichever one
is the higher value interestingly
endurance is really like the only
scenario where macros differ between the
Sexes so women use more fat as fuel and
less carbohydrates but honestly the
difference ends up being like less than
10 gram of carbohydrates used per hour
for women by men so that's like three
spoonfuls of rice and definitely not
something that we need to stress over
too much also interesting interestingly
women have lower protein needs in the
follicular phase of their menstrual
cycle but their needs during the ludal
phases are the same as men so generally
speaking we keep protein recommendations
steady across the cycle to prevent
deficiency so to summarize protein and
carbs are particularly important for
endurance exercise your calorie needs
will be high when doing intense
endurance exercises so even though
protein needs are again quite high
around 1.8 G per kilogram this amounts
to the General Health average of around
50% of your calories from protein a
higher proportion of calories should be
coming from carbohydrates depending on
the intensity of your exercise so around
the 60 to 65 Mark and then you're
filling the rest of the gaps with your
fat so there you have it depending on
your goals your caloric needs and macro
splits will be very different and within
those goals needs are highly
individualized so if you do have
specific goals I highly recommend
working with a dietitian like my
colleagues at unlock I'm going to be
leaving a link to their content below
and on that note that's all that I have
for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you got any
other questions and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye